hello everybody and welcome to part 20
the final part of let's play from dust
okay I'm gonna hold down spacebar to
call the final ritual so let's see
what's going on here
I'm guessing it's something
this action is irreversible bring it on
I'm so ready
whoa all right what's going on here whoa
hey whoa hey he's Pro okay
all right um use the earth okay earth
earth earth earth ah get make land make
land make land
why is it crumbling are the ancients
against me or something ah
scheisse ah pan Judy Dibby Dibby Dibby
neva neva neva David ah okay go go go go
you don't need help help yourselves oh
okay I need some serious land building
serious land building serious land
building here oh my goodness oh my guess
you're there you're there please just
get it done oh my goodness goodness
gravy okay okay okay doo doo doo doo
okay okay okay seriously I'm building
bunk okay that's going up up up up up up
get out of there okay you got your
people are right there four or five four
or five four or five what is going on
here you're right there oh boy okay
bigger Mountain look around oh four or
five four or five what's going on what
is going on you're right there you're
right there five oh five okay babe our
right bar okay oh there we go
okay and everyone's dying oh this is a
phenomenal ending why is this happening
why did the ancients hate us so much
No
huh what okay it's still alive for now
something's happening I see a lot of
five everyone else is dead
okay it's one animal and a whole bunch
of men and women to animals all right
that was something nerve-wracking okay
wait a minute wait a minute this is the
beginning of the game
daddies Nikita oh I got it I get it oh
it's a cycle they start over and over
again
the ancients they are the ancients Wow
that's I guess that's the whole point of
the game it's like a circle a life sort
of thing rebuilding from nothing going
over and over again but wow that's the
end of the game that's that's really
something I mean I I know a lot of you
weren't too into this stuff you
literally like me doing the horror games
and I'm doing do a lot of war games but
I really appreciate a sort of free
building free world type of game like
this and I think this game is only $15
on Steam so and I believe that a lot of
you would have more fun playing this
game then you would have watched me
playing this game this is something that
you need to get your hands on and you
need to just dig your fingers in the
dirt and just get things going just
throw sand around watch lava destroy
your villages just have fun with it and
this is a sort of game that can really
get you behind that so thank you for so
much for watching like I said it enough
in the last video and I say it enough in
the conclusions of a lot of my games but
thank you guys so much for helping me
get to this point like it's you guys
it's you guys going out sharing my
videos liking my videos favoriting my
videos um subscribing liking it's you
guys doing this stuff commenting as well
that just helps me get more attention
and build up and like this is something
that I want to do full-time I would love
to be able to do this for a living and
like maybe with your guys's help someday
I can get to that point and like I love
playing video games and I love
commentating on video games I love
acting like a stupid idiot sometimes
just to make you guys laugh I love
screaming like a little girls just to
make you guys laugh
so thank you guys thank you so much I
can't fit I can't say thank you enough
and but I'll stop saying thank you
because I've said it way too much
already
so just um well a couple more to thank
you guys so much for watching I'm not
going to make you go through the entire
list actually I've got a better idea for
what I might be while I talk um I said I
was gonna do it so I'll do it now I'm
gonna go through each one of these and
just give it a few seconds if you want
to read it pause the video and you can
read through it so but again um the next
few games are going to do I plan I know
a lot of you weren't too into me doing
this game and you really want me to just
do four games but that's not what I'm
gonna set out to do and I'm sorry if if
you don't like that but I put out five
to six videos every single day and I'm
gonna do that every single day I mean
every weekday every weekend and I don't
plan to slow up on that for a long time
like I have free time now I'm at a point
in my life where I have the free time to
do this and do this a lot so I'm gonna
do it as much as I can right now so that
I'd never have to slow up on I have a I
have a stockpile of videos that's why
sometimes you guys are our art telling
me in the comments Oh mark you stupid
idiot oh why do you do that it's because
I did it a couple days ago
and I I don't look I don't look at
walkthroughs I don't look at things
online
I hardly ever watch other people's Let's
Plays well no I watch other people's
Let's Plays but I don't watch Let's
Plays when I know that I'm gonna I'm
gonna watch I'm gonna play the game
myself um but so if you guys will um if
you guys are willing to be with me
throughout doing this I'm gonna provide
it's gonna be sort of a half-and-half
thing I'm gonna have the scares of me
being a stupid little girl and scaring
and screaming and just being wholly
terrified out of my mind for your
enjoyment and then the other half is
going to be me playing longer games like
bigger games like this more artistic
games stuff that's interesting that I
think you guys would find interesting in
this game um is really part of that I
forget where I was was in
Naz and was that powers okay vegetation
and so I'm doing this for you guys and I
really like doing this for you guys so
thanks again this like this whole last
video is just me a big monologue of
thanking you guys and it's really about
you guys I wouldn't do this if people
didn't want to watch well I would do
this if 10 people if I had 10
subscribers and no more and I only got
one subscriber a day I'd still do this
many videos just because I want to
entertain people I want to I think it's
interesting I think if that's a fun way
to live and just case I miss powers and
let go back again and so I want to keep
doing this so but if I have to ask
anything is from you it's just I need
your help getting the word about out
about my channel so I'm not gonna be the
type that's gonna beg and plead after
every single video for you to subscribe
like and favorite I'm not gonna do that
because if you watch my video and you
like what you see I figure you're
intelligent enough to subscribe like and
favorite and comment so I'm not gonna
beg for it at each one and I'm not
knocking channels that do beg some
people have it that you know it's part
of their thing that's what they do but I
don't plan on doing that every single
time I may ask that you do because the
only way that I'm gonna grow is by you
guys getting the word out so but
understand that I'm not trying to take
advantage of you guys just so that I can
play elevate myself in the YouTube
rankings I am doing this for you guys
and I appreciate it and I just am
grateful that you even like my videos to
begin with so I'm gonna end the
monologue there because I'm just
rambling at this point repeating what
I've said before but I'm gonna end it on
thank you guys so much I couldn't do
this without you and I'm gonna keep
doing this for you
so thanks for watching and I will see
you in the next game bye bye